he's the head coach the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers he is Bruce Arians how are
you coach very rich I'm doing great
brother how you don't man it's amazing
the the roads that life puts a turn on
sometimes huh it's amazing it really is
I mean you know eight months ago and
never thought about this but it's crazy
stars align sometimes and everything
falls into place
I'm really excited so let's talk about
the falling into place because when you
were on this show about a month ago you
were mentioning that the Browns job was
the only one that you really be
interested in when did the Bucks job
come on your radar screen well you don't
have a lot of respect for dirt cutter
and the staff and what they did their
petition lights a good friend it that
intrigued me having a general manager I
know and I trust and it's really good
and then gosh my whole staff became
available and coaches like I know what's
going on here everything's just falling
into place and I got more and more
excited about it and to be able to put
this what I think one of the best staffs
and a leg together really got me excited
and can't wait to get started yeah
before we get before we get to the staff
there your history with Jameis Winston
is what for those who may not know well
Jameis was in my football camp I want to
use and I think Nicor 10th grade and
take my son I had a football camp in
Birmingham and I say wow this this kid
talent I actually thought he was gonna
be a baseball player because we've
talked about 95 like that but he won our
quarterback competition and you know I
showed all those kids a Super Bowl ring
and I think it made an impression on him
because he still talks about it today
and so yeah you never know with those
little those little twists and turns
when you're dealing with young people
how it affects their life so in terms of
in terms of that you knowing him for a
while and obviously you know what his
arm is like and you like those guys who
can shove the ball down the field and
we're just showing video right here on
our television side of things of him
doing that to Mike Evans are you
concerned at all about his character and
his ability to understand what's most
important to make sure that football
comes second in that regard
no no can
yeah I mean no I don't I mean I've known
him for a long time like I said we all
make mistakes he's made his I've made
mine and you know I just I feel like
I've got a great feel for him his
excitement for the game his willingness
to work is unbelievable he's in the
office at five o'clock in the morning
and so yeah I have no qualms about that
so he's your guy moving forward Jameis
Winston quarterback there's no doubt no
doubt
so what thing is gonna be built around
him so what do you think he can do Bruce
I think he can win at all I mean he has
the intelligence the toughness and
obviously the arm ability to to lead a
team and we got to put the right pieces
around them obviously we got to do some
things defensively but have anybody can
do it defensively attack those can do it
yeah and that brings me Bruce Arians
here on the Richardson show Todd Bowles
you know when you said that your your
staff became available and I laughed I
mean that that's just only laughter
because of just the way you said it
because clearly the reason why they're
available is they in many cases lost the
jobs that they had in the case of Todd
Bowles with the Jets was that was that a
no-brainer for you as soon as that
happened you picked up the phone or did
that happen before you got the
opportunity with Tampa coach no it was
after
it was after and you know we we had
talked you know he's another one it's
like a son to me so I was more talking
to him about his future you know we all
get fired up inside some mates as I
can't count them all and but then it led
to this and so he thought hard about it
I I was doing my best cell job and and
this and this happened so we're really
excited to be back together
well you said you've been fired so many
times don't forget you were also retired
- Bruce right a couple times do you
think about that right now if you didn't
get that phone call from Chuck Pagano
right can you recount that story after
oh yeah I was what I call be fired in
Pittsburgh and so yeah yeah I'm going
back to Pittsburgh
get the rest of our furniture we had a
little bit of stuff in an apartment
Chuck calls and my wife looked at me
goes how they're gonna take this you
know then that fairy tale story of what
happened that year with him beating
leukemia and Andrew Luck winning all
those games with all those other rookies
kind of gave me an opportunity yeah
that's when you got your coach of the
Year award their first of two of those
Bruce Arians and so now who's calling
the plays because the last time you were
on this program and I asked you about
any health concerns that you had cuz the
time before you were on last you
mentioned now you thought you might have
some sort of medical emergency on the
sideline which led to part of the reason
for you retiring or leaving the Arizona
Cardinals code yeah happily I got a
complete physical on my interview first
time ever and was really glad to do it
and got a completely good clean bill of
health and but no Byron Leftwich will be
calling the plays off obviously I have a
big hand in it and and beyond their
whipping but you know a trained Harold
Goodwin and Byron Leftwich the last few
years to handle that job I feel very
very comfortable with them okay cuz
that's what you said as you said you
know if I go back I'm not gonna call the
plays which is gonna make it a lot
easier for you health-wise so Byron
Leftwich is gonna be the former
quarterback of the Jacksonville Jaguars
who had some time on the staff there in
Arizona he is going to be the play
caller for you I thought you did a great
job
Wow and there's interim role this year
right so what walk me through the health
stuff with you and you I guess you and
your wife and your physician was part of
this decision for you to come out of the
CBS booth here coach yeah yeah I mean
you know we did everything soup to nuts
done in Tampa my doctors were involved
with any questions and so yeah and I'm
other than losing 30 pounds I'm good
shake that's great
so before I let you go here coach just a
few minutes left with Bruce Arians the
new head coach the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
will be introduced
such officially on Thursday what is it
about coaching that that that coaches
can't quit do you think well it's the
relationships if you haven't been in a
locker room and building a team and and
joining and bonding together from one
common cause I don't think you can
understand it and for me it's I missed
the arena you know having been on the
broadcast booth I realize how much I
miss the arena right and so you've
gotten just the the itch that you just
can't get rid of essentially yeah it
really is I mean it's a you know having
all those guys available for coaching
staff to start with takes and light I
mean everything just kind of fell into
place and it got its year and it's year
brother well coach look I really
appreciate the time you calling in I
know you're doing this before you step
to a podium there in Tampa as you know I
I've known you for a while and it's just
it's gonna be fun watching you making
sure that this vertical game keeps going
vertical and that Bowles is coming in
and left which is getting a shot the
folks in Tampa gonna get a shot in the
arm that's for sure and I look forward
to seeing what you do with it brother
you bet it same to you and so on the
hats stay the same color right yeah
that's the nice thing I'll get a few
more pewter ones okay there you go hey
I'll take one you know you got it I will
take it yeah bring back the old popsicle
you knees too if you can I mean when you
go throwback I'll take them a popsicle
I'll take a popsicle color one if you
got that yeah okay got it
Bruce take care Congrats again thank you
go that's Bruce Arians new Buccaneers
head coach at Bruce Arians on Twitter
right here in the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience